>> IF YOU ARE UNVACCINATED YOU
NEED TO BE WEARING A MASK TO
PROTECT YOURSELF AND OTHERS
AROUND YOU.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED TO STOP THIS
PANDEMIC.
OVERALL THE CDC'S
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVEN'T CHANGED.
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO DECISION TO
CHANGE OUR MASK GUIDELINES.
IF ANY DECISIONS ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH WOULD BE DRIVEN BY THE
CDC.
BUT, OF COURSE, WE ARE ENGAGED
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS AND
THE CDC ABOUT HOW TO CONTINUE TO
ATTACK THE VIRUS.
>> Bret: WELL, THERE IS
RESURGENCE, THAT'S CLEAR.
AND NOW THERE ARE DEBATE IN
DIFFERENT STATES ABOUT MASK
MANDATES COMING BACK, NOT COMING
BACK, WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
VACCINE.
THE PRESIDENT THIS AFTERNOON
REPEATING WHAT HE SAID AT A TOWN
HALL LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE
VACCINE AND GOING FORWARD.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE HAVE A PANDEMIC AMONG THE
NON-VACCINATED NOT VACCINATED.
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED, YOU ARE
SAFE.
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED, YOU HAVE
OVER A 98% OF NEVER CATCHING THE
VIRUS AT ALL.
IF YOU CATCH IT, YOU ARE LIKELY
TO OVERWHELMING PROOF SO FAR IS
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
HOSPITALIZED.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE SICK.
YOU ARE PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE
NO SIGN THAT HAD YOU IT.
>> Bret: WELL, THE CDC HAS NEW
NUMBERS OUT ABOUT THAT.
AND THIS -- THESE NUMBERS
ACTUALLY FROM JULY 12TH.
SO THEY ARE A LITTLE OLD.
BUT THEY ARE BREAK THROUGH
COVID-19 CASES, 5,018 AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED FROM
BREAK THROUGH CASES.
THIS MEANS YOU'VE HAD
VACCINATIONS AND YOU STILL GOT
CODY AND THEY WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL.
1063 AMERICANS HAVE DIED FROM
BREAK THROUGH COVID-19 CASE.
75% OF ALL THOSE WERE
HOSPITALIZED OR DIED FROM THE
BREAK THROUGH CASE WERE AGE 65
YEARS OR OLDER.
AND THIS IS THE DELTA VARIANT
THAT EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT.
SO, WITH THAT LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL BEN DOMENECH PUBLISHER OF
THE FEDERALIST.
JUAN WILLIAMS IS A FOX NEWS
ANALYST AND STEVE HAYES EDITOR
OF THE DISPATCH.
STEVE, THERE IS THIS DEBATE AND,
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
BE INDICATING THAT THE CDC IS
GOING TO CHANGE ITS GUIDELINES
SOON.
>> Steve: YEAH, HE HAS INDICATED
THAT AND ALSO SUGGESTED THAT THE
CDC MAY ALLOW CHILDREN UNDER 12
BE VACCINATED WHICH I THINK
WOULD BE A WELCOME DEVELOPMENT
AT THIS POINT.
LOOK, I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE ARE HAVING A DEBATE
ABOUT GOING BACK TO MASKS FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A
DEBATE ABOUT GOING BACK TO
MASKS, IT SUGGESTS THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE VACCINE HESITANT THAT
THERE IS NOT THE KIND OF UPSIDE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PROMISING ALL
ALONG TO GETTING VACCINATED.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF
MIXED MESSAGING THAT WE DON'T
WANT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
HAVING SAID THAT THE ONLY REASON
WE ARE HAVING THIS DEBATE ABOUT
POTENTIALLY HAVING TO GO BACK TO
MASKS IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
IRRESPONSIBLE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRETENDING THAT THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING
VACCINATED AND BETWEEN BEING
UNVACCINATED.
MANY OF THOSE ARE CHARLOTTE TANS
AND HUCKSTERS ON THE RIGHT WHO
ARE IN JUST ASKING QUESTIONS
MODE PRETENDING THAT THERE IS
REALLY NOT MUCH TO KNOW ABOUT
BEING UNVACCINATED VERSUS BEING
VACCINATED OR THAT THERE
♪ REAL SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE HAVE
A BEING VACCINATED PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE TO
SURVIVING TO AVOIDING GETTING IN
THE FIRST PLACE SURVIVING ANY
COVID INFECTION THAT YOU HAVE.
>> Bret: ABOUT THE MASK AND THE
VACCINES, PETER DOOCY HAD THAT
LITTLE BACK AND FORTH WITH JEN
PSAKI ON THIS ISSUE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT
THE VACCINE BECAUSE THEY WERE
HEARING HIM SAY IF YOU GOT THE
VACCINE YOU DON'T HAVE TO WEAR
MASKS ANYMORE.
>> AND THAT CONTINUES TO BE CDC
GUIDANCE.
>> AND YOU CAN SAY THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE GUIDANCE
FOREVER.
>> I'M NOT THE CDC DIRECTOR.
>> I UNDERSTAND BUT PEOPLE DON'T
CARE WHO TELLS THEM TO WEAR A
MASK.
>> THEY SHOULD CARE.
>> WHITE HOUSE.
>> SHOULDN'T THEY CARE IF IT'S A
DOCTOR OR MEDICAL EXPERT OR
SPOKESPERSON?
I THINK ACTUALLY MOST AMERICANS
DO CARE.
>> IT'S THE GOVERNMENT.
>> OKAY.
>> Bret: BEN?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT FIRST OFF,
THERE IS NO BASIS TO HAVE ANY
KIND OF MASKING FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO ARE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL MAJOR POINT OF CONTENTION
AND MAJOR ROLE RELATED TO MASK
MANDATES.
YOU COULD POTENTIALLY SEE AN
ARGUMENT MADE IT WOULD MAKE
TEACHERS MORE COMFORTABLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
CIRCLING BACK TO STEVE'S POINT,
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE EVIDENCE
THAT THE DRIVING ELEMENT FOR
PEOPLE NOT GETTING VACCINATED
IS, AS HE SAYS HUCKSTERS ON THE
RIGHT.
I DON'T REALLY SEE THAT IN FACT,
I SEE ALMOST TOTAL UNANIMITY ON
THE RIGHT IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
RECOMMENDING THAT PEOPLE OUGHT
TO BE VACCINATED.
CERTAINLY AMONG THE POLITICAL
CLASS.
AND IF THERE ARE HUCKSTERS OUT
THERE SAYING THESE TYPES OF
THINGS, I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF PULL IN
THIS COUNTRY IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE TYPE OF EFFECT.
I THINK THE FAR MORE REASONABLE
AND OBVIOUSLY, I THINK DATA
SUPPORTED APPROACH IS TO SAY
THAT IN EVERY ASPECT OF THE
PROMISES RELATED TO THAT
VACCINATION, WE HAVE SEEN THE
GOVERNMENT PULL THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH PEOPLE, OVER AND OVER
AGAIN ABOUT WHETHER THEY WOULD
BE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
TO LIVING A NORMAL LIFE.
AND THAT INSTEAD OF HAVING THE
ABILITY TO GO BACK TO THAT, THEY
ARE BEING TOLD, ONCE AGAIN, OF
THE POTENTIAL MANDATES,
LOCKDOWNS, DEMANDS ON THEIR
CHILDREN, YOU KNOW, PREVENTION
OF BEING ABLE TO GO BACK TO
LIVING THE WAY THAT THEY THOUGHT
THEY WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO IF
YOU HAD A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
AMERICANS VACCINATED.
THAT'S A FAR BIGGER DANGER WHEN
IT COMES TO DISCOURAGING
VACCINATION THAN ANYTHING THAT I
HAVE HEARD FROM ANY HUCKSTER.
>> CAN I CLARIFY.
YEAH.
CAN I CLARIFY?
SO, I DIDN'T SAY THAT THAT WAS
THE CAUSE.
I SAID IT WAS A PROBLEM.
IT IS A PROBLEM.
AND IF BEN DOESN'T KNOW WHERE
THE PROBLEM EXISTS I SUGGEST HE
PAY MORE ATTENTION.
CLEARLY THERE ARE PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY ON THE RIGHT, NOT
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE RIGHT.
>> SORRY PAID A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
>> IN THAT CASE.
[TALKING AT THE SAME TIME]
>> YEAH, LOOK.
IF YOU DON'T THINK IT'S A
PROBLEM, THAT PEOPLE ARE.
>> Ben: CHANGING THE
CONVERSATION.
>> Steve: NO PROBLEM.
IF YOU DON'T THINK IT'S A
PROBLEM THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT WHO ARE PRETENDING IN
THE MANNER OF JUST ASKING
QUESTIONS THAT THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING
VACCINATED AND UNVACCINATED I DO
THINK YOU OUGHT TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION.
>> Ben: I SAID IT WAS A PROBLEM
WHEN KAMALA HARRIS SAID THERE
WAS QUESTIONS ABOUT VACCINES
UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND IT'S A
PROBLEM, OBVIOUSLY WITH ANYBODY
QUESTIONING.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY OF THE
STATURE OF KAMALA HARRIS ON THE
RIGHT TODAY SAYING THAT PEOPLE
OUGHT NOT BE VACCINATED.
>> Bret: JUAN IS ON THIS PANEL
TOO.
I CAN'T WAIT UNTIL YOU GET BACK
IN STUDIO SO THE WHOLE BOX THING
AND BRADY BUNCH THING GOES BY
THE WAYSIDE.
I WANT TO PLAY SOUNDBITE ABOUT
KID MASKED IN SCHOOLS.
BEN MENTIONED IT TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE CDC IS GOING TO SAY THAT
WHAT YOU SHOULD TOO IS EVERYONE
EVERY OVER THE AGE -- UNDER THE
AGE OF 12 SHOULD PROBABLY BE
WEARING A MASK IN SCHOOL.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> I THINK THAT'S A SCARY
THOUGHT THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS MAKING A
FORECAST ABOUT WHAT THE CDC IS
PROBABLY GOING TO DO.
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
MAKE SOME KIND OF BIG DECISION
MORE THE WHOLE NATION IS WRONG.
THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT, JUAN.
>> WELL, IT'S UNLIKELY CHILDREN
UNDER 12 IS GOING TO BE
VACCINATED BEFORE SCHOOL IS
STARTED.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR PRECAUTIONS
TO PROTECT CHILDREN.
I WAS WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
MARYLAND TODAY, REPUBLICAN LARRY
HOGIE.
HE SAYS HE DOESN'T KNOW IF THEY
WILL START DOING THAT BEFORE
NEXT YEAR VACCINATING THOSE
KIDS.
THE REALITY IS THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT THE KIDS RIGHT NOW IS
FOR EVERYONE TO GET VACCINATED.
IF EVERYONE IS VACCINATED, THEN
THE KIDS ARE GOING TO HAVE
ALMOST NO EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS.
I MEAN, WE HAVE A SOLUTION THAT
DOESN'T INVOLVE ANYBODY IMPOSING
ANYTHING ON ANYONE JUST SAYING,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S ACT IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF OUR HEALTH, OUR FAMILIENS AND
OUR CHILDREN IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE VACCINATION.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS NO WAY FOR
KIDS TO GET IT IF EVERYONE IS
VACCINATED.
>> BEN, LAST WORD HERE.
>> Ben: I DON'T THINK WE CAN SET
THESE KIND OF RULES TO THE
FEDERAL LEVEL I THINK TO THE
POINT OF THE PARENT YOU WERE
QUOTING THERE THESE DECISIONS
OUGHT TO BE MADE AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE TO THE LOCALITIES TO
THE PEOPLE AND TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FACING THESE CHALLENGES
WHICH ARE WIDELY DIFFERENT
ACROSS AMERICA WHEN IT COMES TO
THE LEVEL OF CHALLENGE AND I
THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND PARENTS OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
DIRECT HOW THEIR CHILDREN LIVE
AND HOW THEY ARE TREATED.
THAT IS NOT THE ROLE OF THE
GOVERNMENT OUGHT TO SUPERSEDE IN
ANY RESPECT.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, STEVE.
DO YOU WANT TO AGREE WITH BEN TO
WRAP UP THE PANEL?
>> Steve: YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THE PRINCIPLE OF SUBSIDIARY
SUGGEST PEOPLE CLOSEST TO THIS
DECISION SHOULD BE MAKING THE
DECISION.
I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE VACCINE, FINE TO
ASK LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE LONG-TE